who are fascinated by infinity it is so
incomprehensible that everyone wants to
know about it
what's infinity umm which kind of
infinity there's multiple different
kinds of infinity what
well there's countable infinity and
there's uncountable infinities what well
actually you're talking to the wrong
person fundamentally you shouldn't
really be talking to scientists at all
if you want to know about infinity you
need to talk to mathematicians because
they're really the people who deal with
infinities they're the people who
understand the properties of infinity
and so on in science there are no
infinities there are things which are
extremely big and there are things which
are extremely small which is just one
over a very big number but there is
nothing which is infinite or there is
nothing which is infinitesimal very very
very tiny the universe could well be
infinite in extent but actually what we
can observe the universe what we can see
at the universe because light only
travels at a finite speed and the
universe only has a finite age is finite
and so I could well be that the universe
is infinite but because it is not
directly observable in that sense it's
not from a physicists point of view
terribly meaningful to even worry about
that infinity yeah so infinity well the
easiest way is you know to get infinity
is to take any finite number like three
for example and divide it by zero and
you can see immediately now there we
have a problem what value does that have
well if we divide any real any finite
number by zero we'll get get this
infinity and that's the symbol it's all
has that elegance to it that sort of it
I mean it just looks kind of infinite
maybe it's just because I associate the
symbol with the concept but actually
there's just something about that sort
of figure of eight structure that looks
kind of I mean even though you can go
round and round it forever but I think
it was introduced the symbol infinity
was introduced by a British
mathematician called Wallace in the in
the 17th century and apparently he he
was one of the first people to use this
the alternative one which i think is
very funny on the Egyptian hieroglyphs
you find you find the symbol I think
it's for a thousand and a draw a cartoon
version of it but
it's it's something like this apparently
so whether this chap Pierce is or
clearly a symbol of a man and whether
he's indicating that this is a very
large size or we putting his hands up
like this saying go that's a very very
large number I don't know but maybe a
symbol like that would be would be a
better symbol for infinity where
infinities do appear it usually means
you've done something wrong
so for example my colleagues in particle
physics spend a lot of time trying to
calculate the masses of particles kind
of they come up with some theories of
particle physics and use that theory to
calculate the mass of a particle very
often they end up with infinite masses
for the mass of the proton or the mass
of the electron or some other particle
and clearly we know those particles are
not infinite m/s and so actually usually
an infinity appearing in your
calculations means that your Theory's
wrong physicists on the whole don't like
infinities when they crop up in physical
theories we're dealing what we with what
we call singularities and a lot of
celebrated physicists have spent a lot
of time removing singularities and
infinities from problems in physics like
like for example Fineman infinity was an
obsession for mathematicians and one of
the famous mathematicians who dealt with
this problem of how would you deal with
with a number like infinity was David
Hilbert and he came up with the idea of
Patel infinity which I'll tell you about
there's a story about a hotel so imagine
that you have a hotel with an infinite
number of rooms and because it's so
popular it's always completely filled
with an infinite number of guests
however it's possible if you or I want
to check in there the manager is very
accommodating and after a bit of time
you can always find you a room
so the idea goes like this you check
into the hotel and you ask that you ask
the the people at the desk can you put
me in and they say yes yes what we'll do
is we'll move the first guest into the
second room the second into the third
the third into the fourth or fourth into
the fifth six into the center seventh
into the 8th 8th into ninth ba ba ba and
so on and by moving this succession of
people because you've got an infinite
number rooms they go on forever you can
always move a guest in the very large
number room to the next one and so on
to
infinity so you get accommodated and
you're very very happy so then if you're
interested in mathematics you can now
see well let's see how good this hotel
really is
I'll now going to bring an infinite
number of my friends along and you go
along to the front desk again and say
look I know you're very busy I you're a
bigger towel but I guess you completely
full up again they say yes sir we are
but can you accommodate my guess how
many are there there are infinite number
no problem they say you can imagine that
you could take each one of your guests
already in the hotel and if they're in
room 1 you ask them to move to room 2 if
they're in room 2 you ask them to move
to room 4 person in room 3 goes into
room 6 the person in room 4 now we get
rid of and put him into room 8 room 11
goes into 22 person in room 12 goes to
24 so now all my odd number
rooms are vacated because I pushed all
these people off to infinity and I can
come in now with my infinite number of
guests and they are happily accommodated
into the infinite number of odd numbers
so I think I've stayed in that hotel
before it's in London isn't it yeah very
small rooms yeah it seems to be pretty
trivial I expect most people watching
this video will think is trivial as well
but apparently this is still set as a
little problem for people at university
math departments and probably still at
school to think about to make them think
about sets and so on all these fancy
things that mathematicians do but it
does seem awfully silly trivial profit
and creepy we don't like dealing with
that in physics mathematicians love it
in physics we say let's chop it off here
let's let's pretend that liquid is a
continuous fluid but when you get down
to the atomic level it's made up of
atoms which are 10 to the minus whatever
10 minus 10 meters in size again there's
a funny difference between
mathematicians and physicists here
mathematicians worry hugely about the
infinitesimal and the infinite and so on
physicists tend to kind of throw
infinities around in a much more sort of
slapdash kind of fashion so when a
physicist tells you something is
infinite or when in the calculation
something comes out as infinite it
really just means it's very very big but
that would you know have
mathematician tearing his hair out
because actually very very big is as far
from infinity as you can get so we
always try and make sure everything is
finite range so that we can deal with it
and sometimes you have to do the maths
assuming that there is a finite range
otherwise you get nonsense basket that's
one way of putting it you another way of
saying sweeping down to the carpet so
you don't see it and it's generally
thought to be a squeeze that work
because we live in a world without
infinities so my son six and yes this is
the kind of question he likes asking
what if it's bigger than that what if
it's bigger than that and so on and you
know you get into the game of well life
you know I'll pay you ten pounds I'll
pay you 100 pounds I'll pay you infinity
pounds that he likes you know having
that as his trump card so you clearly
have some concept of it already